boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have a super exciting show
super exciting guests we're talking
about the future of investing and we're
going to be talking to Sean O'Sullivan
wonderful wonderful Alan thank you for
having me it's great to be here coming
on the show you're a hard man to get
onto the show so I'm really excited
hello god I'm glad it finally worked out
I was yes traveling a lot yes and you
have like a hundred plus staff you have
150 startups a year that you invest into
which is just absolutely nuts this has
been going on for a while this is SOS
ventures as well as V actually I so sv
yes the recipe and I still keep saying
that because it's it's a venture capital
firm it makes kind of sense but it's
just SOS V historically when it was just
me we called it s what's venture with a
checkbook with me with a cheque for the
first ten years there was this was
ventures and now it's SOS V for the last
you know eight eight nine years it's
become an actual group of people and
institutions in fact yes 650 million
assets under management and investing
next year probably 70 million a year and
then you know the way that we invest
through accelerators a lot of people
come in and follow-on to our companies
and invest a lot more money so for every
for every 50 60 million as we invest we
get another 250 300 million coming in
from all the Sand Hill Road guys and all
the other people from around the world
and this is what is defined as the seed
stage is that the companies come in with
usually anywhere from idea to a
prototype you know and a team of two to
five but generally two or three
co-founders was you know maybe a couple
of years of experience with the market
or getting the product off the ground
sometimes even less you could have a
company with a really great idea that
just came together a few months before
the program started
before we get into you know all the
nuances heed investing in as well as
just investing across these really
important industries of robotics IOT
healthcare food let's talk to you about
how you got here a lot of people are
interested in knowing like how people
get to where they're at right so yeah
what were the things that led you to who
you are today yeah what we do well so
like I started as an engineer and
inventor I created a couple of companies
along the way and that's how it really
started just from college I went
straight into creating my first company
MapInfo which if you've ever typed an
address into a computer and then seen a
street map like you know how I would
have gotten here today or whatever
that's what we invented just that Street
mapping capability on computers
initially and then obviously in cars and
and other things so that became a couple
hundred million dollar company we were
the first adage back in the 80s when I
got started so 85 is when I was twenty
years old like graduating from college
and I started it right right then and
you you knew that computing was just
blowing up that it was gonna be it was
it was a thing it was starting to happen
and it was the right time to be in in
the early stages of the personal
computer industry and you picked maps
which was huge to understand well yeah
it was I like I think that the chance
that early-stage startups have is
creating you know this is Buckminster
Fuller Pro right you know you can't
fight don't you can't win by fighting
the existing reality to really change
things you have to create a new model
that makes the existing model obsolete
so you can't win by fighting the
existing reality you have to to really
change things you have to build a new
model that makes the existing model
obsolete
so you know in the case of Maps
those days that was really the paper
maps
Rand McNally maps were in your car you'd
have to look through and figure out
where you were going and which road and
then you'd pass by and oh [ __ ]
you'd be driving the wrong road for 30
minutes you wouldn't figure it out but
you know the the idea obviously was hey
computers could do some of this better
you know and it wasn't just for street
you know for finding your way around
navigation there's all sorts of other
database applications we took any
database overlaid it on a map and that
was helpful for making deliveries or
doing sales redistricting or you know if
you're you're gonna be tomorrow is the
election right I pray we have a great
results for all humankind on the
election tomorrow and you know you'd you
know all those kinds of maps where you
have to see location by location how
these you know congressional districts
or whatever all that stuff was
originally done on that map info there
are loads and loads of applications that
were just built around that in the early
late 80s early 90s even before the
internet came out and made it more
popular for consumer mapping and were
you doing programming or what were you
initially I was a programmer I was a
president and one of four co-founders of
MapInfo and and chairman for the first
seven years and then and then we brought
in you know professional management so
it took you to like 32 years no it took
me to around 28 28 see graduated 21
there's 20 20 21
yeah yeah yeah yeah so and then and then
from there I I did a yes so but it was
actually just seeing a new opportunity
and building a new model and the same
thing my next sort of technical startup
was a company called net-centric so we
develop software for inside the internet
this was back in 95 96 so you know again
before you guys were born but you know
it was you know we always born that you
made it in Florence you're not out of
your diapers yet so but you know back in
96 you know you know a trademark with
George paddle or a compact computer we
we came up with this term cloud
computing you probably heard that term
and so it trademarked that term back in
97 that's in the Oracle though was
around then well this is like the first
Internet boom you know but a lot of the
you know so the cloud was developing you
know but it was early days or for you
know hosting services back then the
cloud was actually in pops points of
presence you know rather than big data
centers weren't even really a big thing
back at that time and they became much
the way that people think about it these
days yeah so but and anybody that and
that's and that was sort of some of the
technical creds that I have in terms of
a software developer and an engineer and
and inventor I guess what was the come
after MapInfo
what happened with that did that get in
one public so in public yeah and so I
used some of the proceeds of that to
invest and ever since it went public I
was sort of like this angel or super
angel going around and writing 100
thousand half-a-million dollar checks in
early-stage companies and you found some
good ones and I found some good ones got
some great returns you know we have you
know a net IRR 39 percent IRR in
internal rate of return so the VC sorry
yeah so if you basically it's like if
you invest a dollar and then a year
later it's worth a dollar thirty nine
and then
year after that it's worth $1 87 or
something
13% year after you get 39 percent a year
after year down 90 or whatever that
would be you know so it's compounding
you know so then do you have a line of
people that are asking like can we get
an SOC how do we have v2 and I can't
talk about that you could talk about
that minded people okay but after
MapInfo then you you were doing angel
super into work yeah and you also
started he said with George from Compaq
yeah yes so that what that was called
net-centric that's and that grew to be
about I think it was a I think was about
10 million revenue 9 million revenue
company in the last year and 13 million
in expenses and so the Delta well you
know that would be okay in today's world
but in that day that was when the
dot-com crash happened the you know the
the whole crash of the internet so there
was no more money in that that worked
out very unpleasantly for all involved
unfortunately it was sold off but nobody
made any money and it was a real lesson
like my first company I was super
successful
I just thought everything was roses I
thought it was like this you know this
is God you know they could just pick an
idea and be successful and and I had
some good ideas but you know it's
there's a lot of other variables
involved you know I'm glad you had a low
as well because that way you know what
the low feels alright because I've had
so many you try to do really really
difficult things most of the time
they're gonna fail yeah and it's like
you know I give this quote from Gandhi
you know at first they'll ignore you and
then they'll ridicule you to food and
then they'll attack you and then you win
so the only problems you keep trying the
only problem with that quote is if you
can keep trying anything and survive
long enough the only problem is that
many of us can't survive long enough
yeah and so you know maybe 20% of the
time 30% of the time you actually get to
win and so it's a hard hard life to be
an entrepreneur and for me when you were
saying that there's like this there's
this feeling of of entrepreneurs and
artists just people that are kind of
getting by month after month trying to
build what they want how they want to
see the change in the way yeah exactly
look around themselves and what they see
around themselves as they see all the
you know the 96 errors and stuff like
yeah and those people are like you know
and just way more like stable in terms
of like yeah life and whatnot
yeah so yeah so there's like when you
clinked kind of like the bottom of the
socio-economic strata because you're
just so paytrik to paycheck yeah that do
you get a lot of cortisol there's a lot
of stress there's a lot of anxiety and
stuff and you can get burned up about it
you like I think that you know for me I
remember back in the early days of map
info you know running up the credit card
day and I came from poverty in the first
place and I did oh yeah I grew up for I
was our family you know nine kids with a
single mom raising us since the time I
was three
how many kids nine kids you know I was
the eighth of nine oh good so there's
nothing more in upstate New York
winters are terrible you know not I just
did yeah that's a big fan big family big
family and other sisters are all lives
today actually one I had one brother
unfortunately who was murdered so he's
not whoa but the other the other eight
are still around and and all nine of us
you know went to college you know which
is which is a big priority for our
you know irish-catholic mom you know
that they're there that's the number-one
job make sure the kids got an education
and she earned that still say no no no
so he/she was a single mom in that he
divorced or he abandoned her you know
when when we were three so yeah so he
raised you guys always just by himself
yeah which is why we were on welfare for
like six or seven years you know yeah
and then until there were enough kids
that were out of the house that that
were old enough to let themselves go to
school and she could go go work and she
she did and but still it was not easy at
any part of the way but at any rate you
know that was that how can someone be
pregnant for ten years straight you know
actually she had 11 eleven deliveries in
in ten years
two of them were stillborn and so it's
actually 11 full-term pregnancies but
that she had how consider is called the
Irish twins is called I've a brother
who's like 11 months younger than me and
my brother is 12 months Oh 12 or 13
months older than he very very close
oh did she have how she did she didn't
have twins though no Irish twins are
when they you're both within a year
that's cool getting back getting back
right back at it you know I hope that
there's no such thing as Irish twins
anymore I hope people you know that's a
cultural value which is probably gone
god it's the side
you know but at any rate okay that's
interesting about your you know that you
actually had a more low SES when you
were raised and yeah see you got you got
to feel what that's like well yeah I
knew I liked I knew like growing up that
I you know yeah I went from living you
know in absolute poverty as a kid to
living like a college student which is
similar to living in absolute poverty
for many kids anyway and then and then I
went straight into a startup which was
just a continuation of the same thing so
I you know I was okay I wasn't a big
setback I didn't need to get the big you
know I didn't find myself needing you
have to buy a big car or a house or
anything like that it was much easier to
sort of escape by but you know you had
like I have these I had shoes that had
holes in them and then then I and then I
I just a friend of mine gave me he saved
a cop you know one of my pairs of shoes
and he gave them to me recently like a a
year ago and you know I look for the
shoes and I said I was wondering like
you know how because I knew I had holes
in myself a lot of all the socks and
we're getting jeez
Jeff holes in all your socks but there
was a piece of cardboard in the cheese
shoes and that's how I would I would
just be constantly flipping out the
copper new pieces of cardboard it's just
crazy
you know when you go through when you're
when you have to just scrimp and save
there's this thing called ramen pup's
you know like ramen pride noodles and
you get an egg and you and you you know
mix them up together and that's
basically you know you have that once or
twice a day and then you're okay and for
50 cents a day or buck eBay you can sort
of survive you know it doesn't mean you
can pay you know pay the rent in a place
like San Francisco really no not at all
so we were you know we were in upstate
New York where that accompanying up
founded and it was we were able to
get by you know so anyway so that took
years and we you know you know and then
that's crazy switching the cardboard has
to solve the shoe yeah
that story is crazy well you know what
you look around San Francisco you see a
lot of people who are probably doing
that you know walking on this on the
streets I mean I'm talking about the
chance to take posting yeah against the
techies yeah so you know I I can relate
to these situations and not having also
worked in war zones and things like that
it's I can relate to just the tremendous
sacrifice that people have to make to
see the change they want to make in the
world come to be and it takes us kind of
relentless drive and determination I
think together of us and ok so what
happened to see what was the connect is
what was it in that centric right in
that centric net-centric ended up going
in the.com as yeah it's got sold off to
a bigger like a Cisco type okay but it
was not it was not a good outcome you
and then what about the MapInfo went
public but then yeah where's it now well
not even forgot it went public and then
it got acquired for like a half a
million dollars several years later by a
company Pitney Bowes which is still
around those ok yeah ok and then so now
let's take us to post net-centric when
you're is that when so I so after that
Center Goa after net-centric I wanted to
filmmaking for we talked about yeah I
think for a little bit but then after
that I went well I was then I went and I
took my sort of documentary filmmaking
kid goes I was in Iraq for the
during the war years it wasn't allowed
in by the Saddam regime and then was
therefore shocking on and built a
humanitarian organization all that your
your eyes are open it and why does if
you don't know any of this I guess you
didn't do any prep on me I do as much as
I possibly can I just came back from
that 10-day meditation or truth oh
that's good yeah that's good yes that's
fantastic my god that's amazing
i'ma put 10 days of meditation I'd love
that please teach us so what year was
that that's how long she has more 3 2002
the end of 2004
so that was while the while the original
war who was very short like a couple of
months and then you know 2000 and it was
basically from March 2003 to around May
of 2003 and the whole thing was wrapped
up and then the civil war started the
following April of 2004 so that was a
really tough period I went there for
humanitarian efforts but when they were
originally the documentary filmmaker 200
just to cover the the thing and then I
ended up working for like you know doing
freelance work for CNN and Reuters and
lots of other writing or video video
video yeah yeah yeah yes shooting
shooting off other I chewed right you I
shoot the you know some b-roll
effectively of what was going on in the
city you know yeah you know what was
happening in you know with military sort
of things or whatever and then I would
then turn it into like Christian and a
poor or whatever talk to them and they
would they would voice annotate some of
the stuff and put it all together what
would that would that look like when you
were capturing the b-roll and then were
you how would you get it because there
was no like you know Google Drive so how
were you shooting on TV a digital video
tapes like they're little tapes and then
you were literally and we and then I
would go to the I would you know
go to the Palestine Hotel which is that
big hotel and they'll Baghdad where the
press were you know camped out at whoa
at the time and then I give them the the
tapes there were a lot of courageous
people at that time that was even before
then the sort of the military came and
sort of sectioned that off and then and
then then later it was you know sort of
became like the Green Zone area across
the river you know was where a lot of
people were operating out of which was
basically just a sectioned off part of
the city where relatively safe I didn't
live in the Green Zone I lived in the
regular part of the city where everyone
else left but but we were running a
manatorian organization so we built that
up to about 3500 people doing
Reconstruction and demolition and
clearance work for a wide variety of
different needs you know taking the
national library and clearing that out
and and getting it ready for
reconstruction hospitals you know
national museums the universities you
know ministries of Education that did
that on thousands of buildings literally
in Baghdad Fallujah and the Joff you
know all throughout Iraq and this is
because a lot of those buildings were
war-torn or well so I you know the
funniest thing and is that there was a
tremendous amount of the damage you know
there were buildings that were targeted
we're bombed and what I and that was
maybe honestly that was probably four
percent of the damage three three or
four percent of the damage most of the
damage was all the looting and the
burning that happened after yeah so that
was it that was it you know that was the
the incredible things people would just
go in and loot the heck out of because
the it's different than the United
States you think in a way of the your
government as as part of you
you know and and maybe that's that's a
difficult age that we're now in where we
don't think of the government as part of
us but you think of things like
libraries and schools is part of part of
what this you want it's part of society
it's a civil society that we have yeah
but you know fire departments on that in
in that case the government was really
viewed as a tool of oppressing the
people and so anything that the
government had was was just a tool for
oppression so they had no they had no
problem in looting like hospitals or
libraries or fire stations or you know
universities or national museums and
anything else
so everything was looted and then after
the looting was done then they would
burn it to get rid of the evidence a
like it's not like the entire population
was doing this it's only probably 10% of
the population got carried away in it
right but they did not stop and they
were gangsters but it was not stress
that they experienced what was the
societal dynamic like of oppression that
caused the 10% to just really go in in
ravage well it was instant it was
instant you know and there was anger
right so like you know like there it was
a dictatorship for a long time right so
and then the weirdest thing is everyone
was like oh you know nobody really
wanted the u.s. to be there at the time
though you got there and and initially
the first you know several months you
know you know you have children and
adults coming up to you and just saying
thank you Bush Thank You Blair chanting
and all this sort of stuff it was really
just so thankful that they had their
religious freedoms back that they had
that Saddam was finally out of power you
know it was just they were actually
really really great grateful Wow no I
was totally totally blown totally blown
because there was no order
and there is no you know the chaos just
continued and so it was it was what what
ended up happening is I switch from
being I just saw what was going on I
said Jesus is terrible where's the
cleanup where is the effort to
reconstruct you know and you know there
was no plan right yeah you know so it
was that's it you intervened without a
plan what happens when ya throw and
there wasn't any sort of and there's
just so many mistakes and in that in
that situation that are you know it's a
very surprising situation I lived
through that situation and Wow it's
really really interesting times we you
know so we you know we ended up growing
we'd be the largest humanitarian
organization in Iraq doing all the work
that we did you know we got some funding
from the United Nations I started with a
little bit of money that I you know I
started with some of my own money you
know a couple million eyes I saw did
just start it up and then it was even
funded further by some some other
sources and this is still around the
it's well not in Iraq but ended up
happening what is
so we were targeted by the terrorists so
my co-founder
so I always do this I can't really get
through this very easily so my
co-founder was assassinated and
a bunch of our management team we're all
you know some of it was kidnapped and
tortured and it was hard I got a drink
Wow it was a hard time and you know you
know I look back on all those times and
they continued and the team wanted to
continue we did scale it back and but
you know at the height was around 3500
people we scaled it back to about
probably 1500 people a thousand people
for for a while but after a while we we
just had to stop at all this came after
the period of the Civil War and the 10
person that came and took could very
well so that sort of looting and burning
period that was very quick quick and I
was that was very close diluting and
there there was gangsterism that
continued for a long time after because
there was you guys came in to help those
location yeah and we built up and we
built up and and it was after the Civil
War started which went for well that
that started in in April of 2004 and and
really went until you know I mean to
some extent is still going on today but
probably most of it was over by 2008
yeah I mean if you just think of the
United States like the worst wars that
the United States has ever been in I've
been civil the the civil war is and I
say there's only one thankfully
hopefully we're not leading up to
another one but like you know we're
we're you know we lost more in the u.s.
civil war than we have in all other wars
combined my factors because when you
have people against people it is the
worst thing I mean the u.s. we very
didn't play a big role in the death
count of people in Iraq other than
creating the situation where a civil war
be it wasn't like US soldiers killing a
bunch of Iraqi people it was the the
sides having the civil war ending you
know and that was because who came into
power was the well it was there was a
you know there was a there were
elections but they were basically these
bandits and these gangsters and these
clerics you know but Todd al-sadr for
example he was still in power to some
extent and he you know he killed you
know people under his orders some of my
people were were killed
you know from so like they were terrible
you know people that were just trying to
stop any sign of progress and he sort of
we were just targeted because we were
cleaning things up and getting things
ready for reconstruction yeah you know
yeah I mean it wasn't just us I mean Red
Cross was mom the United Nations was
bombed you know he was kind of obviously
eventually come after unarmed civilian
humanitarian organizations and I and I I
didn't you know my god
so what what what was the was their
security helping the humanitarian
organizations or how because if you were
completely unarmed then it's well you
know no there's there's things that you
there's things that you do I mean I
never went around with I just think that
if you you know I'm a bit of a a bit of
a pacifist although I'm also a realist
so I wouldn't you know if somebody who's
coming after me I would I would you know
I would defend myself for sure and I
think you have to be realistic about it
but I also don't want to just be part of
the problem and so building out the
security for us as part of a
humanitarian organization is weird it's
weird it is that's so insane yeah
you're okay though anyway so that was
that was 2003 2004 I met my wife in Iran
you left a pre-civil war I know I was
there during during this during the
Civil War period yeah then part of it
and then then what ended up happening is
I got married so I met my wife hurried I
met my wife in Iraq oh my god she's from
New Jersey she was a serious a war
correspondent so we we matched was so
she worked for New York Times Magazine
and you know Rolling Stone and all these
other places sister can she's a fabulous
journalist you should read her stuff
she's amazing she's got a blog called
knickertwist comm check it out and a
virtuous K&I ck the rtw is decom but so
she's she's great she writes for the New
York Magazine now Jeff something like do
you don't get your knickers in a twist
she's always got an actress in a twist
so anyway so yes so then you've met so
we met there and we got engaged and then
you know then we went home to get
married and get married and the war zone
things sort of stopped because like nine
nine months and seven days after we got
married we had a baby and so as soon as
I found out she was pregnant there was
basically like I was I needed to be
around for my kids and when was that
that no is not for me
we got married in December 31st 2014
there are two thousand four so the end
of 2014
and so I then I stopped going into war
zones like we also expanded a little bit
we did something out during the Civil
War the humanitarian effort continued
but you were back I I left yeah Jim
starts continue to work and actually
there's still some jumpstart for for a
while
you know actually there's still some
jumpstart even today but it's no longer
big and it's in different parts of the
world it's not in Iraq anymore there are
other place in the well then need the
humanities yes yes yeah yeah Wow so
anyway that's a long story there's
nothing to do with technology this is
really important to understand who you
are and you know how you got to worry
well you know there's certain crucial
problems facing the world and I just
thought that's the most important
problem in the world at the time with my
skill set how can I apply it I was a
filmmaker I thought you know I'd go to
Iraq then I was in Iraq and I was like
the filmmaking it was interesting but it
wasn't the most crucial thing that I
could do so I leveraged some of my sort
of organizational skills and I just
started doing things that needed to be
done that nobody else was doing I think
that's what what entrepreneurs are great
at is just filling a you know finding
this unbelievable gap in a market and
needs to be filled and just going and
trying to solve that that that need and
in that case there's no money to be made
but you know I think there's a lot of
social entrepreneurs that that feel that
urge you know Justin's in just the same
way I mean it's not like entrepreneurs
in most cases are really not about the
money anyway you know they're about
they're unsatisfied with the status quo
correct and they need to see a change
and they want to be part of that change
and they want to lead that change yes
you know they they do not want the world
as it stands and you know by being
exposed to it by by being there and
seeing it I was I was frustrated because
I'm an American I was born in America
I'm a product of America and I saw that
we were not doing enough to fix the
situation we were going out with the
wrong wrong solution and the wrong you
know you're trying to apply this
tremendous military force to a
population that's not solving the
problem you know so so you know we have
one hand Ennis how do you empower the
right people of their own cuts their
country you know that that becomes like
yeah yeah how do you do that not that it
says it's a hard it's a hard it's a hard
tough
and I mean I hope that in the future if
things like this arise again around the
world as they are right now in some
places that if we can you know figure
out how to empower the native people of
the part of the world to have the
resources that they need to figure out
how to govern and lead themselves yeah
I'm sustainably over time then well it's
like one of the things that really does
really wait wake you up to is there are
gangsters that in power vacuums will
fill that power vacuum instantly and
those gangsters will kidnap and torture
and they'll use I mean like you know you
know they call it you know Al Qaeda or
they call it whatever but most of these
guys are just crooks and thieves and
bandits and Liars and you know sicko
pervert you know we're no different
because the infrastructure fell apart in
the u.s. here yeah we would have
disabled there's there's a path and
there's loads of [ __ ] that would that
happen even just you know yeah but like
if you if you if you have that sort of
runaway control of having a gun and you
know and and being able to sort of do
things intimidate people if you're a
psychopath yeah you know you you're
willing to do whatever it takes and
without a society to sort of the civil
society to help us keep you know our
morals together and our and our ethics
together you know we're in a lot of
trouble we'd go off very good leadership
we do then we need stewardship for Earth
and we need to assist at we move forward
and
I'm really happy that we made this kind
of pillar of of the conversation yes now
I think it gives a really strong like
ethical and moral footing to wanting to
see this change that you wanted to be a
near AC in the world yeah well and
that's that's the thing like you know
one of the things I determined after
getting back from Iraq and I was living
in Spain for a few years living in
Ireland for a number of years was
actually the biggest change it actually
made in the world in my was in my time
as an engineer and as a creator of new
technologies and companies helping lift
up what was possible and helping improve
productivity of people and you know like
whether it's mapping and you know or
cloud computing just this these are
things that have just transformed what
what it means to be human you know we
can do so much more you know so much
more liberally so much more powerfully
by leveraging the nature of all humanity
on these platform these platforms that
we we now have access to you're doing
something here you know in this room
which is reaching out that would require
a television you know a real television
studio with you know millions of dollars
you know and all this is enabled by
relatively inexpensive technologies
democratizing you know and spreading
knowledge and becoming available to
people so like I looked and I saw okay
the biggest change I can actually make
is to do the stuff I actually started my
life doing and helping building
companies yeah but I know the kid to
that compact you had some complication
yes I have to balance being a child into
the era of the wild doing what you were
doing yeah yeah how many do you have now
I have two kids so I have one child who
is 13 a daughter she's doing great she's
absolutely fantastic you know multiple
fluent in multiple languages and you
know she's just you know an artist and
you know create with man
and whatnot and I have a son who's it's
autism he's 11 and she's a non-speaking
boy and so there's a lot of challenges
and a lot of work involved in trying to
trying to improve his outcome whoa using
sign language or so he's sort of
monitored to severely autistic basically
he if you think of like in my son's case
he has great receptive language and his
brain is very active but up until
recently we didn't know what he knew
because his body can't you know he can't
communicate can't tell you what he's
thinking he can't write because he
doesn't have fine good fine motor
control was a Type C he hasn't been able
to Tyler because the motor control isn't
that good news
all other place but sort of was like the
Stephen Hawking thing you know we're at
least in Stephen Hawking's case he got
ALS you know who later in life so you
knew that there was a brain in there we
never knew my son you know is thinking
and he would she's in this island he
would receive from the exterior
environment right vision and then what
you didn't know even you know what is he
receiving receive Kenny here can he
understand the spoke you know you know
we knew he could say you know I pick up
your coat or whatever or going you know
go upstairs go and yeah yeah but we
didn't know what he was capable of
learning and now we we have him just the
last couple of months using a letter
board and he is sort of typing out
letter by letter whoa the sentences a
letter board yeah he's a letter board
it's actually it's a very low-tech thing
it's just you type a letter just one
letter at a time and it's abusing a pen
actually it's a big it's a bigger thing
it's a stencil board
yeah cool yeah this is like a keyboard
but no no it's no electronics eventually
in another
nine months he'll be on to the
electronics he'll he'll be able to type
but his motor control is still very
limited so this is a Penta he poke it
through home and then I we sit down and
write out what he's read oh whoa yeah
but how does how did how did he learn
laser specialty in the first place to
know how to spell the words so like you
know access to language all the time and
you don't think about it but yeah you
know and we are reading him books and
books and then he's looking at words so
he yes how to spell it to make it work
yeah what is he saying he's so cool I
show you a video but you know we're not
gonna do that but you know well you know
we just sort of teach him a lesson
like we'll say you know a lesson about
you know for example where the chocolate
chip cookie was invented you know so do
you know where the chocolate chip cookie
was invented no in the United Kingdom
okay at a place called the Toll House
Inn Oh Toll House yeah that's cool
there's a little factoid you could
actually take away that you've learned
today and there's this woman who
discovered that you know by mistake that
the chocolate chips could who would not
you know would work in this way and
whatever it was I don't know my son you
know I could ask him today you know you
know where were the chocolate chip
cookie he'll say total house and I'll
spell Tokyo a you know gosh oh so you
know tell him a story and then you spell
the things as he's learning it like
United Kingdom you know the UN ited you
know ki ng do em and I'd say just that
fast as I'm telling him a story I'll
spell us words and then I'll ask him
questions and then say you know what
year did this happen or that was that is
a whole again with the word time this is
kind of where things started is that you
wanted to go and continue pursuing
bringing really good important
technologies to the world right while
you were dealing with raising two
children but you
to invest more time into hugely learn a
lot more yeah yeah Wow yes so that
status and my wife has led that effort
and she has been heroic throughout it
and we we have you know engaged with a
lot and we're very lucky you know
because we can we can afford to discover
these new therapies that but up until
you know up until you know six months
ago I we had never even known that this
therapy was really a successful therapy
we I saw it I said you know we'd heard
some bad things about it and this is oh
this may not work or whatever for the
sketch the sketch with it this with this
spelling to communicate it's called yes
so but in fact it's a miracle because
now we finally know what he know yes yes
and and he's able to you know when he's
able to say anything like you know you
you know you know he you know we talked
about about fireflies and then he's
spelling out bioluminescence yeah yeah I
mean and it's just like okay that's
that's not that's not that's advanced
this is a kid who really is catching on
attitudes and whatever you teach him now
now I wonder if the way that I've seen
sort of breakthroughs work with people
like Tony Robbins REE patterning
people's behavior to be able to speak is
that a potential oh yeah like I listen I
think there's physiological things that
are happening with children with autism
this is a it's a medical and biological
condition and the reason he's locked in
is the same reason not the same reason a
completely different reason than then
say Stephen Hawking was locked in you
know he physically has you know things
that are causing him to you know he it
does a lot of stemming he you know which
is which is repetitive motion he he
you know be making noises like you know
you don't you look at my son and I love
my son and he's a lovely boy but if you
were ignorant you would just think that
he was incredibly like the village idiot
you know you would just think that this
is just there's nothing in there and
that's not at all true yeah and I think
you know as a parent I am you know I am
guilty as well of not realizing his
whole potential up until more recently I
mean I always hoped that he'd be able to
you know someday go to college or
whatever now I know that the only thing
stopping him from going to college is
helping him control his motion motion
the sensory motion just that's called
stemming the stimming semi is like
singing is like the the fact that like
you'll they'll do things like flapping
their hands or doing you know going
around in circles or doing SNe I am as
teeth-like stimulations today which is
spinning yeah Wow okay so it was way off
track I think it's way on track I got it
got to know this this is so important
there's so many different ways right and
this is the thing is that what you
learned
raising your boy is now made you more
empathetic to society that's it and the
lace is and there are urgent problems I
mean this is the thing there is urgent
problems that need to be solved and we
could go and back another social
networking company or another way to do
ad revenue on something or whatever you
know what SOS he is not into that you
know
SOS he is not gonna back another
software app or e-commerce marketplace
that just doesn't really move the world
forward because there's just too many
really critical problems that need to be
solved that are
you know right there with your heart and
in need of whatever people are suffering
day in and day out across the world and
across this town you know and they're
suffering in a lot of cases for these
life science related reasons and they're
suffering because you know they are you
know less productive than they could be
you know we're working across a wide
variety of mostly hardware and life
sciences but also food applications and
food is important to us as well I would
say because we're seeing so much disease
and you know bad food options for people
I mean there's for the last you know I
don't know dozen years or so there's
Mahmood in the world is not a lack of
supply currently it's obesity obesity
yeah right starving yeah yeah and and
all the medical problems that come out
of that I mean half of our half of our
medical bill is due to the fact that our
that we're dealing with these chronic
conditions produced by the food that
we're eating so having better food
options for people and and really being
able to provide also understanding them
micro banca of individuals but you know
what that's best for exactly and and
being able to measure this and being
able to you know improve this with good
feedback loops so devices is time jeez
medical devices I have internet sings
devices in transition that tied back
into better health conditions better you
know gauging if you're dealing with
depression just having treatments for
that whether those are medical devices
that are actually trying to treat that
and using you know new forms of
electrical stimulation you know
transcranial magnetic stimulation those
types of things or just detecting it
like detecting with Gaussian
you know skin sort of mechanisms of to
determine if you are actually in a
depressive mode and then engaging with
you know proper therapies or proper
behaviors that will get you out of those
therapies or out of that out of that
condition so you know there are you know
the world is a physical place and SOS V
is investing in these physical issues
like we have these accelerators you know
you said atoms over bits atoms that not
say yeah exactly that focus on the
physical issues more so than just the
software the software is always gonna be
a big part of it and when you think of
machine learning for example totally you
know machine learning is coming from
sensors you know where the sensors
sensors are Hardware yeah if you're
thinking about really great applications
for AI you're thinking about
self-driving cars okay that's the
hardware problem so many cameras yeah
exactly
okay so let's let's start like this
because I think yeah to wander ourselves
into the vastness that is SOS V is you
you started us off by saying that this
is about solving the pressing challenges
around the world right and that you you
see the the things that are right there
with our hearts that are right there in
our families yeah it's not about the the
optimizing some part of e-commerce or
some sort of advertising platform it's
yeah it's about you know what's right
here next to our hearts the in terms of
the suffering across the world and so
then you you should be good markets you
know that's saying like this is not a
bleeding heart it's not a things that
you can only lose money these yet right
totally absolutely
you can if you create a tremendous
amount of value for people then it is
worth sharing in that value to the
company creators and
the people who backed those companies
and and and that's that's easily you
know you can see through automation you
can bring so much value and so much so
much new capabilities to people new
productivity to people that it is always
going to in a well-designed system
create create value if as long as the
company can get out there and get the
product at the market and the people
love that product and you you mentioned
this earlier and I and I still am
feeling it with residents from the
meditation retreat as well just the
notion that you you earn enough for
yourself for the people that are
dependent on you and like the community
around you and then you give and you
give and you give without expecting
anything in return you just give because
that is that's where so much of the
meaning in the and the purpose yeah
comes from well and then that's why I
like for me you know we're our
foundation is about getting investors
that really care about helping people
like all the general partners that SOS
fee are focused on maximizing the
the growth of the the founding team
because that's how we we benefit so
giving to those people but also the the
whole network around accelerators great
accelerators is to be very engaged with
great mentors and youth mentioned you
yes and mattress at Indy bio absolutely
and maybe it hacks as well so like we
you know that is a critical component
just having you know people that that
just really want to help the the
journeys that were on we can do
shortcuts we can open the doors we can
you know you know find the gatekeepers
of yet given industry or the gatekeepers
of finance and introduce people to each
other and those those things can make
this greater creation happen we live in
an age of abundance right now and the
issue is it's not distributed very very
yeah there should be you know the this
age of abundance should allow us to live
in a you know world of mutual prosperity
and and greater prosperity for everyone
and there's no reason we can't strive
for that in our investing methodologies
and our and our process I have done
deals with lots of VCS and lots of DC's
are not actually in it for anyone I have
to say but most most of raw truth well
it you can see it you can see there's
there's there's zero-sum game you know
VCS where you know or negative sum game
VCS where they would rather destroy
something than create create a greater
whole I mean the the thing I love about
creating technology is that it's a
positive sub game you look at war in
Iraq it's a negative sum game all the
money you spend it's destroying lives
destroying you know buildings destroying
you know everything's a waste the entire
no matter how much money you put into it
it's destroying it's a negative sum game
or as always a negative something games
poker is a zero-sum game right Louise we
we bring 22 bucks to the table you know
if at all yeah you know it's a zero-sum
game yeah
and and then the positiv same game is
technology and education always a always
away if you do it right for it to create
more value for everyone around the table
and so that's why I fundamentally you
know in my life journey like I'm brought
back to technology rather than just
spending all my money in charitable ways
like brought back to technology because
I think it it can lift all of us so I
you know so that's what you know these
accelerators are trying to do is to take
you know these stagnant segments of the
economy that needs to be you know
disrupted and energized with new new
possibilities and then just driving
those possibilities forward and I can
tell you that it's so gratifying because
we are making so many discoveries you
see the you see nd by now right
you know you you probably know a bunch
of the entrepreneurs that are going
through and you know we have new cures
for like pancreatic cancer you know
these things are getting to market will
be getting to market soon we have you
know I don't know which companies you're
aware of that are in tommorows batch but
there are stocking shockingly great
advances and that is gonna create a lot
of value and opportunity and a lot of
grateful like I'm grateful just to work
with these founders because of what
they're doing in terms of creating
meaning and purpose even in my own life
yes correct
you know so that's just life sciences
yeah and then there's anything for
biomedical devices you know you know
there's so much so okay so that those
are kind of these the categories now I
want to talk about the accelerator model
but yeah but you're a long side that I
want to also pair that with what you
described earlier which was extremely
good people even extremely good mentors
extremely good investors people that are
there to do a positive sum game to
increase the PI over time and also to
solve some of the world's
and problems I like how you talked about
in mentorship being so critical in terms
of especially these little shortcuts
that we can find finding the gatekeepers
pairing the right people to young
they're all this kind of stuff okay so
now the the the SOS V has around six
right now accelerate yes right yeah and
so what's what's interesting is I want
to ask you about the accelerator model
because most people I don't think most
people know that that accelerator model
popping up around the world is a really
good way for the advancement of
entrepreneurship and for kind of the
also the the the centralization somewhat
but also decentralization but all but
you centralized in terms of knowledge
and skills and and writers and talent
and stuff to open these doors and that
way more people can come in through that
yeah well you know I think accelerators
you know it's a challenge because it
still has to work economically it still
needs to work right these things need to
be able to support themselves or if they
don't support themselves they need the
graceful you know participation of
corporate like there's a lot of
corporate accelerators that probably
wouldn't be alive except for the
corporations or sponsoring them and
government-funded accelerators that work
the same way think we're sustainable
themselves as well but on a on the kind
of model where it can continue to grow
and build you need to be able to have
the companies that are going through
you're paying a price for the equity of
those companies years later it needs to
be worth more and more right you know
and there's a lot of companies that are
not going to make it at all so you have
to you know it's how you get your IRR
that's how you get that IRR back up to a
good level is when some is by creating
some phenomenal value like the world has
never seen and then just that explodes
you know
the the return so you can do it more you
know it's but but like I think back you
know my first company I was very very
grateful and lucky to have some mentors
that a senior vice president at General
Electric Warren program and this guy
Harry F Clair en forma he'd started at
5060 million dollar company to join our
boards and became like these on your
board them yes that's how you were able
to move forward with that no yeah yeah
how do you do how do you do it like you
just you get some help you know and yeah
and some people who are just generous
with their time and really you know
helping you open your eyes I knew
nothing about cap tables or this
corporate sales or you know I mean I
knew nothing about you know you know I
knew nothing about actually really
managing people and you know the funny
thing is like first-time founders you
know if you look at the most valuable
five most valuable companies in the
world they're all companies that were
all first-time founders so that's kind
of weird you think oh Jesus I mean and
actually if you look at the house and
it'll road invest they only invest in
people you know oh they'll write the
checkbook is open if they've done this
deal need money for that
here's five million we get started
but actually if you want to be you know
a Google or you know you know Sergey and
I are here
or Apple you know steven steve' or you
know what are the other five top ones
Amazon Jeff Bezos and you know you know
not Netflix actually was not first time
China but he's not in the top five but
the you know there's there's a couple of
the other ones where am I forgetting
help me did you do jobs I did yeah
dis Apple did you do my gate Zuckerberg
yeah there you go yeah there's another
one so you know yeah but those all were
you know all those companies that are
you know half a billion and they're half
a trillion to a trillion in value cause
top five most valuable technology not
just technology the five most valuable
companies all first-time founders so
they all need a lot of help
yeah and they got there and created some
of the most phenomenal changes in the
world because they had some mentorship
they had some you know early investors
we're targeting first-time founders
accelerators target first-time founders
it's their first chance and and
economically you could still do
extraordinarily well you know with
backing first-time founder companies
like you know those you know so totally
we we're we're recognizing that you know
they're that foundation establishing a
really good foundation early on can help
companies go further faster yes
so so tell us about then the kind of the
seed accelerator ecosystems that have
been built out there's different there's
the hardware there's the food yeah it's
like we started actually with China
accelerator so like you know I was an
early investor in tech stars they
actually I co invested with this guy
Brad Feld he was a co-founder of tech
stars and runs founder group and when it
expanded to Boston from Boulder the guy
who started it up I'd also invested in
him previously Sean Broderick and so I I
invested in the tech stars Boston said
wow this is a great model and I
been looking for a while for a way to do
more scalable VC you know because we see
it's not very scalable even even if the
accelerator level it's not hugely
scalable because you know there's it's a
relationships it's a service with
services business right you have to
really really mind the store and so so a
rage was it was the idea of giving like
the 250k for like eight percent equity
this back then it when it first started
you know when we first got into it like
eight nine years ago it was $20,000 you
know or back even before that was like
$6,000 per founder like it was 12,000
$18,000 you know is what you'd get for
your 7% or whatever now he cow yeah
that's all it needed back then well
that's what it was and that's all
software focused software is not yeah
software's not cheap either
yeah you know that's still with
electricity and so that's yeah it's it's
it's scalable you know but you you know
only if you have a small number of
people who are living on ramen fried
numbers so so but you know the card the
cardboard says she's and that's how you
that's how you maintain I was very lucky
we had the majority of the company the
founders had the majority the company
went along public so it was it was
because we didn't raise a lot of money
because we when we did get a Greylock
came in but we were already profitable
if I'm guerrilla and invested in us so
like you know that kind of orientation
is less common the these days like where
you're looking a lot of times people are
looking and I love bootstrap businesses
I love the
businesses where they're not thinking
though we got to get the money for the
VCS we gotta get the money from the
customers because if it's really
something valuable you're doing you can
get the money from the customers they
want it you'll pay you you make it so
that's not always true and things like
Life Sciences well and hopefully in art
and entrepreneurship that there can be
more recognition for helping out
entrepreneurs and the artists that that
so need people to recognize that the
things that they're taking are giving be
given in many ways for free artists or
entrepreneurs make content like this
this video-content right we want we
never want to charge for this ever it
needs to be democratized for anyone
around you to watch and learn that's the
point yeah there are models that that it
works in that way but then it becomes
advertising exactly and even then even
the whole advertising thing is like I
you you would want someone like you know
an indie bio company when you're doing a
biotech show to to be one of them maybe
the companies that you plug like this is
super relatable yeah what we're talking
about yeah versus the way that the ad
economics works now is just it was
blocked so the whole point is that one
of these points sorry for me that it's
just so dear to my heart and you know
Paul is Paul let here is you know
directing producing the show with us and
he and he has produced video content
that's before and he's in the similar
wheelhouse of bit of making art and
making in this case of entrepreneurial
content that people have come and sat on
our show with us Sean and when and they
are artists are entrepreneurs and
immediately afterward there's almost
nothing that feels as good for me at
times yeah just being like you know
here's 20 or $40 patronage towards your
thing so that you can continue as a at
least the minimum that we can do you
just help you you know even that little
tiny bit if we could just change the
night and I'm writing about this in so
many different ways right now but if we
could change the ideology of like I've
made $30,000 I'm going to buy a Tesla
now if we
changed augment that a little bit and
just say what if I gave 30 different
artists $1,000 each yeah yeah yeah what
would that do to the world yeah well
that's all that's almost becomes into
the your you're talking about the
universal basic income possibility as
well which is actually way more
interesting than I when I first looked
at my cell that's crazy but actually
it's not so crazy but anyway that's
that's another that's its first number
to talk about but you were asking me
what was the history of the creation of
these and so I said like I got involved
with the text artist thing a little bit
early and I said this is a great mall
this is exactly the right way
cohort-based
small groups of you know 10 or 15 people
learning from each other sitting in the
same space I just love the the the that
that that that model you know 10 or 15
teams you know 30 or 40 50 people you
know working together having that
journey together so we said okay well
we're not going to duplicate that
because techstars has that one they're
expanding in the US or whatever let's do
it in a place let's do in a place where
it's completely different so we went to
China and we set up our first
accelerator in China because what we
were in Dalian originally in the onion
province is close to North Korea oh yeah
the north of Beijing it's north of
Beijing east to Beijing okay and then
it's now in Shanghai but Dalian is a big
outsourcing centers like the Bangalore
of interest so there's a lot of a huge
number of but anyway it's that that's
why we started there and you're now in
Shanghai now we're in Shanghai Shanghai
is sort of like Beijing Shanghai are the
two software places the biggest software
places in China so but anyway so we
started in Dalian because where did you
start in 2009 is when we
that's a nice when we got the wheels
moving 2010 is among the first cohort
graduated and okay now tell us about
this the co how did you guys end up you
know structuring like who were the
companies that you would let in and how
would you what how did you figure out
okay this is the amount of money we're
gonna give them for these percentage
equity yeah and then you know how do you
build a mentor ecosystem around great
artists steal so we just sort of copied
the the model and also there's another
organization called YC which is also
doing it they have a different model
they're less sort of cohort based I mean
it's like it was court I think it was
more cohort based back then now it's
sort of like this massive sort of
banquet hall filled with people or
whatever on Thursday nights or whatever
it's like going to a wedding or
something but like yeah but like we
actually we like the sort of the 10 or
15 teams all together learning from each
other tightly co-working co-working
environment and these are short metrics
I'm then 4 to 6 month 4 to 6 month
batches you know so that accelerator
model so that is how we started in China
and of course China's software is
completely different than any other
where in the world or any other place in
the world because the Great Firewall so
you can't run any of the software that
runs elsewhere in China that's weak it
doesn't work at all so you have to you
can't use any of the like Microsoft
Office products and oh you can use mic
you can use off-the-shelf products like
they're running on your laptop but you
can't use cloud software because they've
they've basically created this
artificial barrier called the Great
Firewall which forbids it's like Google
services aw well as you know all this
stuff none of that works in China they
have propped up their own economy using
that way so oh it's it's it's it's a
it's a it's a genius it's theft of
trillions of dollars so actually when
people put is a genius in terms of
economic stimulation for China that they
forced them to in absolutely they would
not have
what they have today I mean it would
have been genius alternatively we've
been genius of the United States to not
allow China to ship any hardware or
physical products to the United States
and the force do you know what though as
to how you manufacture our own Wow but
we were in a globalization mode and they
were in a hey let's just take advantage
of the rest of the world mode and it
worked for China so you know and and I
have to say in China's favor they have
actually risen the economic prospects of
hundreds of millions of people from
poverty to middle class and so that is a
great social good that came out of that
despite the fact that they have been
playing with a very uneven playing field
for a long long a firewall is in Clayton
so yeah it's a round ten that's been
around since the me is that since the
beginning like 20 plus years yeah well I
don't know when they started you know
it's all it's all filtered anything that
goes in is not only filtered and blocked
it's also gated like with the like
basically around a 300 millisecond delay
every time you do any anything so it
makes the performance of anything that's
not actually in China completely
unacceptable and so you couldn't run any
cloud services okay unless they're based
in China so that and then of course they
also do other things they don't allow
you to do things like media or whatever
they're not they're not like they don't
license you to do those things so that's
about what China accelerator batches
anyway so we knew that we knew that
China accelerator was you know a new
brand new software marketplace things
that run inside us off inside of China
only can run inside China so we built
some companies to help build some
companies that started there and and now
those companies are many in many cases
more cross-border applications you know
the Chinese companies are going to the
rest of the world or rest of the world
companies trying to take their
applications and build them special for
China
using the the different services because
they don't all the infrastructure all
the api's everything is completely
different inside China so so anyway so
we started that and out of that very
quickly came you know the idea is well
we had some people that were applying to
China accelerator especially because it
was China that were hardware companies
that were doing some hardware devices
and so we ran a couple of batches with
some hardware companies and we said well
geez this doesn't make any sense
why would you have a hardware company
inside of it it's awful I'm sorry
completely different problems yes yes so
we set up a separate accelerator in
Shenzhen and focused on the
manufacturing marketplace and the you
know the supply chain issues and the you
know repeatability and getting a bomb
build materials you know front pricing
range and just you know mechanical
engineering industrial design all the
things you would need to have if you're
going to do a hardware accelerator yeah
so we and we have like 25 28 I think
technical staff at hax that do just that
you know very piece in yes interesting
because that's yet that supply chain and
design and engineering is yeah right so
that's how you know I mean if you can
actually manufacture something for
production you have to have you know
many manufacturing engineers that will
do mechanic you know mechanical design
for manufacturing which makes it
producible so that you can do injection
molding say or yep or whatever else you
need to do the curves need to be just
right it'll be manufacturable you don't
these are not issues when you're doing a
prototype these are things to come into
place when you want to do a thousand or
five ten thousand or a hundred thousand
these things never come into issue when
you're making software right and never
exactly so so it's it well because of
that reason we specialize and so you
know we very quickly set hacks was 2012
that was six years two years after the
first little over two years at the first
one a number two your second accelerator
was happened that was that was hacks and
so I mean like but that really was
established Isis China accelerator that
well Cyril Abbess Wyler established both
China accelerator and hax he's based
here in San Francisco now
I'm again Cyril Cyril heifers father
Cyril Cyril at verse while I'm sorry
yeah it would be interesting to get
through a visionary Punk yeah he's great
it was amazing it's amazing please
connect us would love to yeah yeah and
and through through those through hacks
actually this time we met Arvind Arvind
was over in Shanghai at a time and
Duncan you know they were I do that I do
yeah and so and then we and then we
brought Arvind back to San Francisco and
you know Evan came back to San Francisco
and then we hadn't set up in Dubai
here and that was 15 2015 or 2014 14 you
know he started or maybe in 2013 he
started with like a leap accelerator and
then and about the first cohort ran in
2015 yeah so it's a long story but again
I focused us on the the where we thought
we we were needed and the
differentiation we wanted to bring to
the world we are very deep technical
celebrators like you know we have PhDs
molecular biology and pharmaceutical
sort of developments and you know we
have all of these people on staff that
are helping the companies directly which
you need in a deep tech sort of approach
the the staffers are not at associate
they're at like hacks or Indy bio or are
they at well so we have brands like
hacks in Indy bio and China accelerator
all of the people that work for any of
the brands are actually just as so SV
staff they are they are they're all
staff so are all part of the team
there's one global team Alex and Alex in
June RSS feed Sam yeah yeah and they're
you know so but the brand it's kind of
like a Procter & Gamble they have like
Tide and Clorox or you know you know all
these food companies you know have
different brands you know we have
different brands one overarching way of
doing the business and one overarching
mission of making the impossible
inevitable right making and lifting and
helping founders go further faster you
you know and and just and that is the
through line of what we do just to try
to help these these these companies get
to the first you know de-risk them help
them get to milestones where they can
get additional capital where they have
revenues where they then can you know
build a successful company and give us
give us a taste now as we kind of you
know work our way out give us a taste of
the the China accelerator fruits and
some of its in design an accelerator is
a first accelerator it actually has you
know I'm told it's the most profitable
four year olds startup in the world and
I whoa which is a company called bit max
it's a next and exps
big it basically is sort of a Bitcoin
market Alex oh but it's it's a crypto
currency exchange and okay and you know
they're generally either number one or
number two in terms of the most active
volume they're say Queen bases you've
heard of corn base yeah so they're 20
times bigger than coinbase 20x by the
trading volume so the coinbase home base
is a really big player in the united
states but and they make their money off
of they make their money off of
transactions fees which are actually
quite high but max it's in the 3% or
they're kind of high that's high right
yeah it's like a bit max the reason why
they're in many like like there's a
there's another competitor that's come
along recently that's sort of you know
sort of had a neck-and-neck with it max
as being the world's most largest but
for the last you know several months bit
max in general has been doing around
half to two-thirds of the world's volume
just in one that one platform and now
all the other three hundred four hundred
digital
exchange the crypto currency exchanges
would make up the rest of that now
there's basically us and another player
that's also up there so it may make
their money then transactions as well
yes like five basis points on the
transactions generally like being on a
like they trade you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars you know or
hundreds of thousands of Bitcoin level
transactions J so those generally add up
to between a billion and a half to you
know to you know say six or eight
billion dollars worth of transactions in
a given every day and they just make a
tiny tiny amount on each one of the
contact of a percentage yeah five basis
points is like 0.05 percent so coinbase
that's its yeah but that's why they do
twenty times the volume that or thirty
times of I in that a coin base it would
do because people if they're going to do
a trade are going to do it on a low-cost
exchange and that's why they get 20x of
our yeah Wow okay
so that's and and they're immensely
profitable so this is a come before
years ago from China sorry four years
ago and it's making you know tens of
millions of dollars every month
Wow and profit many many tens of
millions of dollars every month and they
have a big team now and not that big of
a change small see a small team to their
about its profitable as Nasdaq is but
Nasdaq gets thirty five hundred people
and they only have I think they have
less than 100 people okay so that's a
taste of China accelerator how about
yeah so that's a that's a great comes
but there's loads of other great
companies that games holds an
accelerator shop pal and you know loads
of this will be another interview number
two conversation will go I want to defin
by our company's the whole celeea
agriculture movement came out of Indy
bio so you look at nobody's like men
Memphis meats which makes me without
cows or you know Indy bio and rebel bio
and you're a perfect day which makes
milk without cows
there's loads of fitness foods a lot of
the cellular agriculture also some of
the plant-based protein substitutions
like you know producing things that
taste like me but are actually
plant-based that's kind of like what
people think of mostly because that's
what usable in the marketplace right now
but if you eat three times a day so it's
more like right there in our lives
yeah well also but the cellular
agriculture movement is is further away
like you know you got Bill Gates and
Tyson's foods and all these guys yeah
spending you know investing tens of
millions of dollars into these companies
now to ramp up the production but it's a
brand new style of production and so
it'll take a while before it's in Costco
and and whatnot it's in such an infancy
state right now yeah so that's a huge
space we just had less effect on the
show oh good food Institute and so we
really went in depth about how infant
the stages so you can still get in and
explode and make tons of profit for
really good reasons yeah yeah yeah and
it's moving the planet forward like in
terms of the ability you know
sustainability they go with global
warming issues and all that so that's a
big you know very successful area but
there's pharmaceuticals
you know the company called syntax which
I they talked about you know as a a what
looks like a very viable cure for
pancreatic cancer you know it's it's
been done in several animals now and now
or it's going on and actually it looks
like a whole platform because there's a
number of other there's another number
of other cancers that are affected not
just pancreatic cancer there's the
healthcare side of how therapeutic side
there's there's there's other types of
you know you know pesticide eradication
things things that make bees more
productive you know
yeah I deal with all the sort of global
sort of issues around this and you know
and one company that's pretty dear to my
heart I have a son with autism you know
there's now a fraud autism blood test
I called bio so you know so yeah that is
a that is going to be a major major
breakthrough as a diagnostic making that
available to its to people - at age six
months to know whether or not your child
could be developing autism and then if
it is just due every sort of thorough
surveys yeah early stage interventions
yes - move move that forward and also
that leads good Diagnostics also lead to
good therapeutics because you once you
know exactly how to diagnose ities
disease then you can target each of the
elements which is producing the
diagnostic anyway that's a little bit
technical obviously but it's really
great to look at all of these new
applications we accompany tomorrow
there's going to be showing that Oh
they've got the data back just over the
weekend that they have reversed
Parkinson's in mice Wow yeah so that's a
really really massive massive thing and
you know companies like kidney which you
know the first implantable artificial
kidney million people a year die from
kidney not being able to get their
kidneys replaced except Lobley yes I
think that's blue yeah
and so okay so that's all the incredible
stuff with life sciences and then with
hardware packs we've got robotics and
you know things devices so like you look
at companies like mate BOC which does a
you know it's like a Lego for robotics
STEM education tool there
you know they just I think I just saw a
post it said the 384 million dollars I
think that's the market cap I don't
think that's their revenues their
revenues I are you know in the hundred
million style range so there we have
quite a few hardware companies that are
doing extremely well on revenues we have
in that whole SOS beat portfolio
probably most of the revenues are from
the hardware companies with the
exception of bit max and this we have
you know more than two dozen companies
doing twenty million in revenue or more
already you know and these are very
young companies visa
so we're yeah you know and a handful
that are doing a hundred million six six
or eight companies are doing at 100
million or more in revenue I really am
excited to unpack those companies and
what they do we'll save that for another
sit-down yeah we can actually go deeper
into yeah hacks and shine accelerator
and Indy bio and talk about those most
successful or then also the most
impactful in the world and that would be
a lot of fun said yeah it's a lot of fun
there's a lot of amazing devices this is
know thank you so much this number one
was so important because we got to know
you and we got to know all the really
tough stuff yeah there's a lot of you
know about you that that's about it's
like how like whatever they say cynic
simon Sinek something about it's a why
start with fly yeah start with why or
it's about who you are not what you're
doing or something in some ways I don't
know but like it's the core of what we
do is about and recognizing the the type
of problems that we want to change in
the world you know you know you look at
the mirror you know be the change you
want to make you know so anyway thanks
so much for having me yeah Sean this has
been this has been such a tremendous
pleasure absolutely it's I
I feel really just I feel like a whole
new connection because you know knowing
you at this more deeper level being able
to share this with other people I think
thank you the kind of the most like the
most Rudy Rudy parts of who you are been
and also how those are flourishing into
the leaves yeah and and I and I love I
love being able to do that with people
so thank you thanks Sean thanks for
coming onto the show I want to I didn't
think I was getting at a bench
psychological not to get into my
backstory I did but they're not then we
would have states at the leaves and
whenever you show people just the leaves
then there's like but how did the roots
make the leaves right know it's existed
that's it's it's the motivation and I
think it's why we've been able to
attract so many great like-minded people
to SOS V that are in it deserve to
recognize that we're here with a passion
with a desire to actually make the
change in the world not through just
some sort of ego filled sort of hey
we're gonna do this but because you know
what we're not satisfied with the world
as it is and we can help these guys we
are the air to be of service to humanity
but in but directly to be of service to
the founders this is a huge difference
when you walk into a situation and you
look at with dollar signs in your eyes
and you're looking at just the leaves
verse of that of the tree verses when
you come in there with a hope and heart
and you come in there with intentions of
wanting to make the world a better place
and you radiate that outward and you're
there with the roots and you want to be
a part of the roots of the tree that
will take you so much further
in life so mark that as a really really
prominent part of what you know what we
care about and okay just a couple
closing thoughts for everybody thanks
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear from you give us a
comment below with your thoughts and
also do check out SOS V check out Sean
on Twitter also a huge thank you to Paul
Paulette thank you for producing and
directing the show much appreciated
our normal Ronnie Vargas is out busy we
love them so much as well join us in the
community we need your help in order for
us to continue scaling we've been
invited to now travel quite a bit and
interview other prominent people and in
order to do so we need your help join us
on patreon join us via cryptocurrency
the links are below we would love your
help so much than growing the community
join us on our public telegram to have
these thought-provoking conversations
and go and manifest the future go and
build go and build the future we love
you so much thanks for tuning in
everyone
and we will see you soon peace